why don't we go to Nico from Illinois
Nico from Illinois welcome to the
program what is on your mind today hello
Nico
Nico we heard you I don't know why you
muted yourself
all right there we go
uh hey David uh this is my first time
calling in and I kind of just had a
question about social media and
influencers and how they subliminally
push kind of right wing ideas
and how they kind of get these kids that
follow them to believe into these
right-wing ideas and what's an example
kind of educate them what's an example
uh just with like Andrew Tate and all
that stuff that's going on with him I
feel like there's a lot of
um influencers out there that kind of
like support him and try to make him
seem like he's this really cool guy see
here's the thing about that Here's my
thought Nico and I this is an ongoing
conversation that we can have and I I
just I'm not sure it seems that these
types of people appeal to exactly the
same folks and what I mean by that is
you know I did this segment a few weeks
ago about
um liver King and Andrew tane and Jordan
Peterson and I didn't mean to say that
they are the same in their ideologies in
fact they are quite different but the
point was they end up pulling in
basically young men often with less
going on socially than they would like
often less relational you know less
involved in relationships than they
would like often without a defined or
successful career path yet and so they
end up being different flavors of
characters that pull in the same types
of people people and I'll give you an
example
I don't know anybody and I'm sure they
exist anecdotally but I don't know
anyone who works in you know has a good
job as a lawyer or as an accountant or
or you know even a success whatever and
is sitting there watching Andrew taint
videos you know what I mean it just it
seems like it's it's mostly young men
that get sucked in so while I agree with
you
that it's a bad thing that these figures
pull people into this sort of like
pseudo right wing
pull yourself up by your bootstraps type
ideology it's really only afflicting a
particular demographic group
overwhelmingly
right and I was just just because I was
just wondering this because I had seen a
report that supposedly in the UK they're
kind of like re-teaching these young
kids to try to get them away from these
like Andrew Tate effect and all that
stuff so yeah I just didn't know if that
was like a good way to go at it or if it
was just kind of like a waste of time
because at the end of the day these kids
are going to go home and just watch what
they want to watch you know that's true
and you know I know a high school
principal I was recently it's actually a
middle and high school principle and she
was telling me that she's aware of
seventh and 8th graders who watch Andrew
Tate and that's really the risk because
these these kids haven't even really
defined anything about themselves yet
and that's where it's like now that's
that seems like a particularly
pernicious age at which to be consuming
that type of nonsense
yeah exactly exactly yeah and like it's
not like
they kind of let you form your own
opinion you know they kind of just force
the stuff on you and yeah without a
doubt it's just not something that I
would want my kid to
be exposed to you know I agree I agree
well I appreciate the call
yeah thank you for taking my call Sir
all right take care there is Nico from
Illinois very important declarations I
think